one of the strictest abortion laws
enacted in this country since roe v wade
takes effect in texas today now it bans
abortions after six weeks of pregnancy
the law's opponents say that's before
many women even know that they're
pregnant it comes amid an uproar over
another republican-backed bill that
democrats say will limit people's
ability to vote nicole killian is
following both of the measures nicole
intense feelings on both sides about
these good morning to you yeah
absolutely galen the supreme court did
not act overnight on an emergency
request to stop the new texas abortion
law from going into effect opponents
warned it would essentially overturn roe
versus wade by outlawing nearly all
abortions in the state the law is known
as sb-8 and went into effect at midnight
not only does it ban abortions as early
as six weeks into pregnancy it also
allows individuals to sue anyone who
helps a woman get an abortion and those
who are successful in their lawsuit
could be awarded at least 10 thousand
dollars this is happening in a much
larger context state legislatures set
the record this year for the most
abortion restriction signed in one year
since roe versus weighed in 1973
meanwhile the texas state legislature
approved a republican-backed voting
restrictions bill tuesday the measure
would ban drive through voting set new
limits on early voting and provide
protections for partisan poll watchers
republicans say it's to strengthen
election security democrats argue it
would disproportionately impact voters
of color and those with disabilities
they even came here to washington for
more than a month to try to stop the
measure so now as the bill hedged to
governor abbott's desk voting rights
groups are threatening legal challenges
vlad
all right nicole killian we'll see what
happens ahead thank you